Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
junior Arianna Klein survived the
shooting she and her father Andrew Klein
join us now from parkland Florida after
attending attending yesterday's
listening session with the president at
the White House it's very good to see
both of you
thank you for joining us I know how
difficult this situation has been
although we can't really understand it
and what you've all gone through you
were amazingly poised yesterday Arianna
at that White House event I watched
every minute of it and I know the
country and just rallying to all of you
and your reaction to this news that we
just learned a few hours ago about how
the security detail who did have a
weapon didn't enter the building your
reaction to that well you know as a
father Laura and thank you for having us
it's just maddening to hear that news
you know when you when you put your
faith in the law enforcement to act to
protect your children and then they fail
to act
it's just inexcusable and you know it
highlights the other failures that led
to this tragedy that they're contributed
to this tragedy which was a breakdown at
the FBI and failing to act on the tips
that they had the prior failures of the
BSO so I think that people need to be
held accountable
this deputies have parently been held
accountable but I think we need to
continue to look at who's responsible
for their failures to act in these
circumstances
Arianna also in the investigation they
found out that the security camera
footage that I guess the officials on
the scene at the time were reviewing was
delayed so they weren't getting
real-time information about what was
happening inside the building there was
a several minute delay so they were
reacting to things that had already
happened which kind of defeats the
purpose don't you think
Arianna your reaction yes yes well I
think it's disgusting that a police
officer on campus he knew his job and
for him not to enter the building were
harmless like innocent children being
shot is just disgusting and I think that
in regards to the technology Department
and the fact that the security footage
was 20 minutes delayed
it should never have happened and that's
one of the simple issues that everyone
can agree on that needs to be fixed we
need to be proactive instead of reactive
we can't have these security footages
being looked at after the matter last
night at the big CNN town hall event
there was a lot of raw emotion one of
the students who wanted to attend but
didn't attend because he was it was
upset that it's to him it seemed like
his question was being scripted for him
he spoke out tonight on Tucker's show I
want to play it for you and get your
reaction let's watch they had taken what
I had wrote and what I had briefed on
and talked about and they actually wrote
the question for me but but not with
your words I mean they put their own
words into your question even after
after they'd asked you to send the
questions in but that seems dishonest on
it definitely did and that's kind of why
I didn't go last night
originally I had thought that it was
going to be more of my own questioning
to my own say and then it turned out to
be more of just a script and she had
actually said that over the phone that I
needed to stick to the script
Ariana what's your reaction to that that
CNN denies this by the way but they have
a history of planting questions that
Michelle Malkin and others have written
about before in other events but Colton
Taub who gave that interview was he was
emphatic about his point yes well I
think the whole point of the town-hall
meeting was to hear the kids and hear
what we had to say and for that to
happen is inexcusable our voices need to
be heard and he should have been able to
ask any question he had to ask but
instead we have these networks that
don't want us to give our real opinions
and they want us to further their own
agendas
Andrew it seemed like most most of the
students Andrew had had the same opinion
on what to do namely to ban certain
weapons to you know to trash the NRA to
be really disrespectful to Marco Rubio
and nasty things being said to dana lash
who was there but they all seem to be
pretty much in agreement as far as i
could tell there was no diversity of
opinion among either the students or
anyone else that I saw even in the
audience and Laura that's not surprising
at all I actually spoke to a CNN
producer on on Thursday the day after
the shooting and the producer insinuated
to me they were looking for people who
are willing to espouse a certain
narrative which was taking the tragedy
and turning into a policy debate and I
read that as being a gun control debate
and unfortunately I think a lot of the
people talking about gun control don't
understand what they're talking about
because I'm a Republican I'm a gun owner
I'm a responsible gun owner and we talk
about gun control it's not about taking
guns away from people like me it's about
keeping them out of the hands of the
people who should not have them or
irresponsible for a threat to society
and when you know last night when Ted
Deutsch kept repeating his mantra that
he wants to eliminate any gun that can
fire 150 rounds in six minutes
that's almost every gun that's out there
so this suppose that assault weapons ban
these other items are talking about
aren't going to accomplish anything you
know along those lines so I I agree we
need to make some headway we need to
raise the age to buy a rifle I agree
with the President on that but beyond
that a lot of these folks who were
yelling gun control gun control really
don't have a great grasp on what they're
talking about so Andrew let me just get
this straight so the CNN producer who
called you right after the shooting
said specifically what about the way
they wanted to produce interviews and so
forth well as I recall that the producer
said you know we're looking for people
who want to talk about the policy
implications about what happened in
terms of she didn't mention guns but you
know in terms of the policy implications
for preventing future mass shootings and
if you know folks who want to talk about
that we'd like to speak to those people
very interesting Arianna and mr. Klein
thank you so much for joining us our
prayers continue to be with the people
of parkland then you guys are incredible
you were amazing yesterday thank you so
much thank you